not only is asap rocky and rihanna's
love going strong
[Music]
now a source is telling e.t about their
crazy connection
i couldn't tell you how happy i am quote
rihanna is asap rocky's dream girl and
has been for a while
he's so in love with her and they have
the best time together
[Music]
e.t source says they're always laughing
but also connect with each other on a
deep level
i love it quote they just get each other
whether it comes to their senses of
humor or
career aspirations and more they have a
crazy connection
and chemistry and are such a cute fun
loving couple
she may never wear it but she save it so
our babies will be flyer than their
parents
the 32 year old rapper opened up about
their relationship for the first time in
the june july issue of gq
on wednesday calling rihanna the love of
his life
quote i think when you know you know
she's the one
asap has previously been romantically
linked to kendall jenner
chanel iman iggy azalea and tiana taylor
while the 33 year old grammy winner
split from her longtime boyfriend hassan
jameel
in early 2020 and later that year in
december
a source confirmed asap and rihanna's
love connection to e.t
at the time a source told et quote they
have always had
amazing chemistry and rihanna relates to
asap and it feels
natural easy and fun she feels very
comfortable around him since they've
known each other for such a long time
and feels a connection to him because
his dad is from barbados
rumors of a romance between them first
sparked last july when riri featured
asap in her fenty skin campaign
to me in in the industry he's one of the
guys that like
everybody loves their skin i mean i've
always wanted to know like how the heck
do you have better skin like half these
girls i mean like what what do you do
at the time the umbrella singer opened
up to et
about why she chose him for the ads i
wanted men to be represented
because this skincare line is gender
neutral and so i needed that male
representation
in the campaign and so rocky and the
names
as x we wanted that male representation
so men knew that it was okay